-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
It is time to play
"Egg Roulette."
But I'm going to need some help.
[ Drumroll ]
He won a Golden Globe for
his portrayal of Elvis Presley
in the movie "Elvis"
and now he's nominated
for an Academy Award
for Best Actor.
Please welcome Austin Butler!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now!
♪♪
-Thank you.
-Come on.
That's Austin Butler
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Higgins, would you like to
explain how this works?
-Yes, James.
Here in my hand,
I have one-dozen eggs.
Eight of them
have been hard-boiled.
Four of them are still raw.
You and Austin will take turns
selecting one egg at a time
and smashing it upon
the top of your head.
You won't know which eggs are
raw and which are hard-boiled.
You must choose an egg.
-What?
-Once you choose it,
no put-backs.
You must smash that egg
upon your head.
-Okay.
-First one to get
two raw eggs loses.
Austin, would you like
to go first?
-You got this, bud.
It could be any one.
What do you think, audience?
-Okay.
What do you think? This one?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-Good luck!
-You feeling good?
-I feel good about this.
-You do?
-I think so.
-Go for it, man.
-You said break it here?
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
1, 2, 3...
Ooh!
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
We're off to a good start.
-That one?
-That one's a little shiny.
-That's shiny.
I'm scared of that one.
-I'm scared of the shiny one.
I'm gonna -- That one? That one?
-Yeah, why not?
-That looks cooked to me.
-Somebody said, "Why not?"
-"Why not?"
-Why not?
-Oh! I don't feel
good about this.
-Oh, this is fun.
-It's not fun.
Is it fun?
-Yeah. Come on.
-Are you having fun?!
-Come on.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes.
-I just squashed it so hard.
-That was amazing.
-Whew!
-Alright.
-That was it.
-6-4.
-That felt like it was
going to be raw.
Whoa! That means there's a
lot of raw guys in there, bud.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, man.
Alright, I'm going to go
with this one.
-Ooh! That's the biggest one.
No, I just tried that.
It didn't work for me.
-It didn't work?
-No.
-Alright.
-Thanks for being here. Yeah.
-3, 2, 1...
Ah!
-Ooh!
-Whoo!
Alright. Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've never --
This is the closest game --
-Is this the closest?
-Yeah, we've ever played.
So, these are all raw.
I just -- Everyone in
the audience is going,
"Yeah, why not?
Just take it."
That one.
Where's that shiny one?
I'm not doing the shine --
No, I don't --
-That's the scary one
right there.
-That's the Boston Shiner.
Don't touch that.
-Eh, I'll do it. I'll do it.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh! Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel real good.
I say -- I feel good.
I feel good.
-I feel good about this.
-Yeah. Good to see you, man.
I'm so happy
you came to the show.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-Thanks so much.
Congrats on all the success.
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-The shiny one.
-That's amazing.
Dude, this has never happened.
-This is --
-There's four raw eggs in here.
-The odds are 50/50.
-Oh, my gosh.
Half raw, half a-cooked.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-Alright.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Lordy have mercy.
-First one to two loses.
-I'm going to go with this one.
-Alright.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What in the world
is going on?
Dude.
I've never ever -- This has
never -- I swear to God.
-Never!
-Really?
-Are any of them raw?
-I cannot tell you.
-They're all hard-boiled.
-This is insane.
-Now the odds are
against you, James.
-Oh, geez.
-More raw than a-cooked.
Oh, hey! Hey! Oh!
Pick me!"
-Oh, man. Oh, man.
-Hey, why not?
-This can't go well --
-No, it's I feel -- I know
this is not going to be --
-Okay.
-Yeah, this is not good.
♪♪
Aaaah!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It exploded.
I think there's a sniper --
There's a sniper in the --
What in the...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-Oh, my God.
-That's a good look.
-Thank you.
-Oh, my God.
-Alright, ready?
-Oh, wow.
-Odds are back in your favor.
-This is my future.
This is my future.
-Ooh, what are the odds?
What are the odds?
-Oh, man.
-What are the odds?
[ Breathes deeply ]
Um...
♪♪
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?
This is...
This is the
most ridiculous thing.
-This is not good.
-If I break it, I lose,
and you -- That's it.
-Oh, God.
-When it's your time,
it's your time.
You know what I mean?
-Oh, man.
He's got his time
in the spotlight.
-This is the time for you, bud.
Oh, my gosh.
-Are you going to pick
a raw or a cooked?
-Get a cooked egg.
-Get a raw, man.
Go in style.
-Get a cooked egg.
-Good for your hair.
♪♪
-Alright.
-Austin Butler,
thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-I think you did an
egg-cellent job in "Elvis."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
-Wow. First time ever.
-Has that never happened?
-The champ. The champ!
-Oh, my God.
-Austin Butler!
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
-That is how you do it.
Austin Butler.
We are talking to Austin
after the break.
I'm going to take a shower.
Stick around.
We'll be right back.